bladesmiths welcome to the forge your
task today is to build one of these
weapons here that is featured in
history's mini-series event coliseum
we've got quite a few options here what
are you thinking
run fire
that is a good choice
the romfia dates all the way back to 350
bc and was a popular gladiator weapon
due to its lethal effectiveness in close
quarters combat
featuring a long single edge slightly
curved blade and a two-handed handle
this lethal weapon was designed to
deliver deadly slashes and overhead cuts
upon an enemy both on the battlefield
and in the coliseum
the rumpfiah was previously crafted by
fortune fire bladesmiths back in season
four where they struggled with the
massive length of the blade and the
handle
we have eight hours and eight hours only
for you to complete your room fires in
go my fashion gentlemen good luck
because that time starts now
my billet is going to be 1095 center
5920 outside and then mild steel outside
of that
they gave us 12 inch pieces i've never
forge welded anything that long
ah waiting on steel to heat it's
terrible it's helpless is what it is and
there's nothing i can do to make this
heat up faster once i get the correct
temperature then i go over to the press
once i see that good solid weld i start
drawing out the billet i should be on
good pace that's beautiful
i'm really worried about the arc of the
blade
it's a small window a half inch is tough
an arc like that i don't want to go home
because i miss a parameter
jason's angle of curve is a little bit
more acute than the one we have for the
sample which is nice and smooth
all right jason just went for a quench
wow
i pull the blade out of the oil i find a
couple of orbs
i'm gonna see if i can just grind them
out but they may not be in grinder range
if it's not coming out
i'm gonna have to put some heat on this
blade and try really hard not to break
it
the next step is handle construction i
don't want to try to get too fancy and
lose the time that i have the handle
goes together well and it's time to get
the handle shaved
and then a sharpening edge on it
i decided to go for an adc or v2 core 15
n20 outside of that and then mild steel
cladding
now that i have my billet welded
together it's time to draw it out this
is great he's setting halfway do a
section while it's hot reheat do the
other section that's smart work
it's time to prepare for the quench
there you go nice color
oh there's a little bit of a warp
so what am i gonna do to fix this i'm
trying to get the warp out of my blade
and then i look at the spine and my
heart drops oh
jesse's got a crack running almost all
the way down his spine
i am devastated
this is probably the worst thing that
can happen right now if i just left it
there it would probably fall apart on
the first hit on anything
there is definitely not enough time for
me to restart i need to find a way to
fix this now that's so bad i go over 14
605 possibilities
and i decided my only course of action
is to weld the spine
he ran that mig down the back of that
blade that's smart i hope this works
i've welded along my entire spine and i
can't help but notice how ugly it looks
now
ah
i have this franken blade
but i'm very confident that i can get
this mangled heap of a mess to still
perform
with all the flaws in my blade i want to
make sure that my handle is perfect that
in some really nice shaping to that
handle it looks great
five
four
three
two
one basement turbine machine this battle
is over
gladiators of the forge welcome to the
keel test
i'm going to take your own fires and
deliver some choice cuts on this big
carcass
jason you're up first you ready for this
doug i'm excited for this
so am i let's do this
so
all right jason let's talk about your
own fire here first up let's talk about
your handle no issues whatsoever it is
nice and smooth i appreciate the gomi
pattern that you have going on in your
blade and your edges razor sharp but
during that test your blade took a
little bend
right here
but overall sir you're on fire
you'll keel excellent
jesse
are you ready sir i'm ready let's do
this
nice
nice
jesse let's talk about your own fire
here once again
very clean lines
now your handle it really feels good in
the hand i can really control it and
feel the edge when i'm moving your
weapon you had a lot of issues earlier
with your spine but guess what you
survived no issues with that now your
edge is sharp overall sir you're on fire
you'll kill nice
[Music]
my turn to play
all right gladiators it is that time the
time for our dynamic strength test the
skull chop and foam tube
jason you're up first you ready yes sir
okay
hmm
damn
all right jason so it's got a lot going
for it there's some things that draw my
eye one is the the curvature it has this
bend as opposed to being this sweep to a
claw and the other being the handle it's
good feeling but but your eye kind of
goes to the
swoop here and the dip here and the
there's a lot of movement here that's
not necessary but it certainly performed
well and cut beautifully so nicely done
thanks dave all right jesse earp are you
ready i'm ready
i always you know we ask you if you're
ready and i don't know why we are it's
like jesse you're up next and that's how
it is
uh
[Music]
all right jesse so
love the lines that you came up with
this uh your grinds are beautiful and
your work around was smart this held
this blade together that one foam pillar
that didn't cut that's kind of on me i
didn't really hit that at the right
angle but it cut beautifully nicely done
thank you
we'll play smith it's all coming down to
this a simple pull of the cloth now
jesse if you win that's four titles
twenty thousand dollars and chance to
continue on now jason if you win today
that's your first title five thousand
dollars you'll be asked if you want to
move forward in the next round you both
did a great job in our test but only one
of you can leave here today with the
title of gladiator to the forge and
receive a check for five thousand
dollars gladiator of the forge is
jesse sir you've done it again
now jason you battled hard you gave us a
great blade but unfortunately it didn't
make the cut and doug's gonna tell you
why jason you performed very well in
this competition but the design you have
is a little bit off in the sample that
we had and the band you took is
significant and these are the reasons
why
thank you well jason you're talented
smith but unfortunately your time in
this competition has ended i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor congratulations man keep it
up thank you good job jason well jesse
that makes you a four-time glady the
forge and you have 20 000 in your pocket
congratulations
thank you now jesse as you know this
will be your fifth competition and if
you win this battle you'll be receiving
that bonus check for ten thousand
dollars on top of the five grand in the
title so the question is do you have
anything left in the tank and you do
want to go back into the forge
that's what i came here to do
awesome man definitely going on well we
can't wait to see you work again in the
fourth floor man we'll see you there i
don't know how i came out on top but i
did
i feel feeling
so good
i've won four battles in a row now i
have so much adrenaline coursing through
my veins i want to go all the way to the
end i've come to prove something i won't
let myself sleep well if i don't make it
all the way to the end
you